there will always be negative voices and
sometimes those voices can appear to be
outsized
and sometimes they can appear to be
painfully loud but you can
use your own voice to drown out that
noise
because that's what it is but your
voices are those of truth and hope and
your voices
can and should be much louder meghan
markle was
on fire during her unscripted keynote
speech at the virtual girl
up leadership summit on tuesday it's
such a joy to speak to you today
to young women around the world who
aren't just poised to change the world
but have already begun changing the
world the sussexes have made it very
clear that they don't want to be doing
commercial deals which maybe seem to be
tacky and if they are doing public
speaking engagements then
they are relatively safe they'll be
talking about the things that are
important to them
racial equality mental health gender
equality the sort of topics that they
are using to define themselves
these will be speeches about the issues
that are important to the couple
the duchess of sussex addressed over 40
000 attendees in 172 countries
via webcam from her home in los angeles
i want to share something with you
and did she share megan spelled out how
we all need to work together to face the
challenges plaguing our country
encouraging young women to fight for a
more inclusive world
calling on them to call out politicians
now many of them that are worse
they don't listen until they have to
because the status quo is easy to excuse
and it's hard to break but it will pull
tightest
right before snapping in fact throughout
her speech
the duchess encouraged young leaders to
use their voices
and support one another while fighting
for change on issues ranging from gender
equality
and racial injustice to youth
empowerment and the importance of
creating a healthy digital community
you are standing up and demanding to be
heard yes but you are also
demanding to own the conversation megan
applauded
young leaders and their advocacy and
encouraged them to keep fighting
i say to you keep challenging
keep pushing make them a little
uncomfortable because it's only in that
discomfort that we actually create the
conditions
to reimagine our standards our policies
and our leadership to move towards real
representation
and meaningful influence over the
structures of decision-making
and power and the former actress had
this to say about
overcoming fear and often it's fear that
paralyzes us and stops us from being
brave
but don't underestimate that you have
some of those answers within
don't underestimate your
in addition to emphasizing the need to
trust your gut
megan revealed her biggest struggle
throughout her advocacy work
the hardest part and it was the hardest
part for me
is to chase your convictions with action
the growth and the change that you're
pursuing might not feel like anything
day to day
but when you look back i promise you
will see that it all
adds and just in case you need a little
help along the way
i will be cheering you on so will my
husband so will archie
as you all continue marching advocating
and leading the way forward prior to her
speech a source close to the duchess
told e.t
why she's so passionate about advocating
for women
quote the duchess strongly believes that
the next generation of girls and
young women have incredible power and
have already shown themselves to be
leaders beyond their years
they are a generation that is
challenging norms enacting real world
change
and leading global movements what's more
the source adds that megan doesn't just
believe the next generation
is not only poised to change the world
megan thinks they've already begun
last month the former actress delivered
a similar inspired message to the
graduating class of her alma mater
immaculate heart the only wrong thing to
say
is to say nothing